so so that was the other thing that
sparked drama now you've got leaked
phone calls you got the CEO calling a
guy crazy he said she said and so that
raised the profile of what was otherwise
kind of a small thing as the thing on
Reddit small things could turn into big
things that's like part of the beauty of
Reddit and that's what was happening
here dude all right first of all your
energy is gonna be psyched this is a
this is a great story because I have a
little more for you here are you ready
this is the part that that's the
background okay now let me give you some
foreground right let me give you a
little future future play here okay
foreplay that's okay
[Music]
all right what's up we're here um dude
have you seen this Reddit Revolt that's
happening are you aware of this I am
aware of it and uh is it gonna matter
really so basically what happened is
there's this app called Apollo right
Apollo yep here's kind of the I would
say the zoomed out version of the story
so
what's happening today is If you go to
Reddit right now the whole site is down
so they broke all of Reddit what they
were trying to do was just a bunch of
subreddits of these communities on
Reddit were trying to protest some new
Reddit policies so it started with a few
of them that said you know what we
disagree with this policy change that's
going on
you know we're going to do this 48-hour
blackout we're going to go to private
we're gonna go dark and they called it
Reddit go this suburb it's going dark
and more and more started joining to the
point where 7 000 subreddits including
some of the biggest ones on there like r
slash funny and r slash picks and stuff
like that and I believe that's 30 of
Reddit that's what I read yeah it's
basically it's a huge amount like uh you
know this there's there's this couple of
cool websites that you can go to in fact
uh we should go to to one of them right
now so
um go to this site so it's red dark so
red dark dot untone.uk very strange site
but uh you can see in real time this
thing's almost like this this tool is
even almost broken because so many are
going dark at the same time uh and Ben
if you could share your screen so it
says
7240 out of seven thousand eight hundred
and six that's like 90 or something
right 740 out of seven eight oh six
ninety three percent of subreddits have
gone dark
um which is just an insane number and if
you do it you can if you click the large
thing there's like a live of feed it'll
be like
um animals with jobs has just gone
private 5 000 members music music uh
hoarder has gone private 5 000 members
um crusty Windows has gone private and
they just see like in real time and I've
been watching this since yesterday it's
crazy when I when I opened this up
yesterday it was at 2000 and now it's
basically all of them it's 7 000 out of
out of 7 200 out of 7 800. so almost
every subreddit has decided to join this
protest and so you say well what's the
policy what's so bad and what happened
is Reddit wants to IPO so Reddit wants
to go public in the future Reddit is not
currently profitable they make about I
don't know somewhere between 400 500
million dollars a year roughly and um
they're still not profitable
and these apps that other people have
made called third-party apps were just
used to like you could browse Reddit and
they built like special features into
them that made them maybe easier to use
for certain types of people power users
or moderators things like that so that's
why people loved Apollo is because they
had some power user features that were
great for moderators and the Reddit made
the mistake of not they were thought
they were picking on Apollo but in fact
they were pissing off moderators and
that was a really really big issue and
I'll tell you why in a second so Reddit
goes and says hey look we can't keep
giving these third-party apps full
access to Reddit this has a couple
problems first they're hitting our
servers with a bunch of requests that
costs us he said what the CEO said was
tens of millions per year in server
requests the second thing is though
server requests are now serving Reddit
content onto someone else's app so that
person could monetize their app and
Reddit doesn't get a piece of that so
they were like all right we want to cut
costs we want to increase revenue and
they had a third problem which was they
didn't want their data going to all
these different places because basically
open Ai and chat GPT had the scraped
Reddit was like one of the key sources
to make chat gbt so good and Reddit kind
of was asleep when they did the first
scrape but now they're like oh no no no
if any other AI company wants our data
you're gonna pay us a huge amount of
money for it so to do that they needed
to to basically pay all the data they
needed the data only to live inside
their own their own walls so they upped
their API pricing they basically said
for every server request you do it's now
going to be whatever 10 cents and uh a
fake number but but the result was that
a app like Apollo which is made by this
basically this one dude who made it you
know as a passion project at a college
he would have to pay 20 something
million dollars a year just to maintain
Apollo and so he's like dude that's
unfeasible like he's like I have uh 50
000 paying users they paid me 10 bucks a
year so he's like I make 500k on this
now I have to my costs are gonna in 30
days my costs are going to go to 2
million a month
and he's like uh that obviously kills my
app and it kills not just my app all of
all the third party apps
and reddit's answer was basically like
shrug like you know all right well sucks
to be you and um and then the way that
they kind of responded well so wait hold
on I want to ask you a question about
how the word got out but first we had to
get background here which is
even though so I just looked it up
Reddit is like the ninth most popular
website in America and even it's like
you know it's like when someone says uh
no one you know says they use it well
it's like uh you know no one goes to
that restaurant anymore it's too crowded
it's kind of like that so Reddit is
basically an uh uh I don't even know how
to describe but basically a hundred
thousand plus forums all on one website
and the reason why this matters is
because each Forum which is called a
subreddit and there's basically a
subreddit on any topic you can ever
imagine in most viral news in America or
viral memes start at Reddit and it's
subreddits are forums that are owned by
volunteers so someone comes up with one
and they create it and they run it and
then they run it and I didn't realize
how much autonomy they are giving given
and the reason why this is poor is
important is now like this has happened
before apparently Reddit fired one woman
named Victoria like eight years ago and
she was a community moderator and
everyone loved her and so all these
other subreddit it Forum leaders like
did the same thing but where they shut
it down a little bit now
the result of that was the CEO got fired
they got two back then they got 200 000
people to sign a petition saying Ellen
Powell needs to get fired and so she
stepped down like I don't know a week
later or days later after that happened
so they you know they they do wield a
lot of power they yield a ton about it
so but here's what's crazy a Reddit
doesn't make it that much money for how
large it is if you look at the top 30
websites in America I bet you
I I'm not researchers but I would make a
bet that it's on the very very low end
of Revenue or even value created per
user per user and part of it's because
people are Anonymous and redditors are
typically horrible with clicking ads and
things like that uh and the other part
of it is that they're kind of in a weird
way this guy Steve Huffman and Alexis
Ohanian they created this company Reddit
and it's amazing and their users own the
platform a little bit and that's what
we're seeing here is these people
basically set their channels or set
their subreddits to private so you can't
access them so that's what's happening
my question to you is when this guy will
call him Apollo an Apollo guy announced
that he was going to shut down his app
how did he get word out that it happened
and how did all these people rally
around this well again the people that
use this app were power users and so
when he said hey guys you know here's
what's going on and it actually happened
in multiple steps so the reason this got
so much heat is because it happened in
multiple stages he said they announced
the they announced that they were gonna
update their pricing he's like hey we're
gonna have to keep an eye out for this
but I'm optimistic like I'm sure
reddit's not gonna
they're not gonna like just do something
that doesn't make any sense and right
it's like for sure for sure we're
obviously gonna take this and take
everybody's needs into account but we
will have to update the pricing and he's
like you know what that's reasonable
I can't wait to hear back what you guys
have in mind that was like post one and
he shared that but where'd he share this
he shared it on subred on Reddit or
maybe in Apollo subreddit plus some
others and so like the mods summary
because again a lot of moderators like
Apollo and because it helps them do
their job faster
um because these guys they're subreddit
owners make money no they make nothing
so Reddit has this huge Fleet like of
the moderators that are in the dark one
I think right now there's 28 million
moderators I think that was the number
um that are that are like participating
in this some some insane number let me
see uh I had a subreddit it was called
like apartment hacks and I was like
trying to get people and it very quickly
got like a thousand people but I I quit
working on it so I got the number wrong
28 000 moderators on the 7 000
subreddits so that are participating in
the in the in the blackout basically so
these moderators basically they're
constantly fighting spam so when you
have a site that's as popular as Reddit
there's a huge amount of people that are
trying to get you to buy their crap that
are trying to get you to subscribe to
their only fans that are trying to get
you to click this link and install this
virus and or just doing clickbait like
just making it where they post something
super outrageous just to get clicks and
engagement upvotes in a big battle in
the comments but then it kind of turns
off people who were there for like you
know they wanted they wanted the
entertainment without it getting ruined
without the party getting ruined and so
the moderators with the people that were
keeping this house party working where
it's like yeah we want people to come
here and have fun but no dude you can't
bring 17 kegs in here no you can't just
come here and flyer your own party
inside my house like no no you can't do
all that crap and they're fighting this
constantly and they do it as a giant
unpaid thing now what they pointed out
during this protest very reasonably was
that
dude where red is one of the only
networks that's all run by unpaid
volunteer moderators so for example
Facebook has a huge moderation program
they spent about 200 or 300 million
dollars a year just on moderate content
moderation Twitter spends a bunch of
money on content moderation
um and so content moderation can be a
very big cost center it's of the
moderators are like hey you're trying to
save 10 million dollars by shutting off
these third-party apps have you thought
about what happens when we stop doing
all this free work and like now you have
to pay for Content moderation or this
whole site goes to [__] like uh what's
gonna happen then maybe you should
listen to us and so that's the that's
where this is escalated to but I'll but
just to finish the story so he goes he
said he says up front Okay Reddit
announces change it's going to affect us
but hopefully it's all good and some
people in the comments were like dude
you're being naive these corporations
are they're like just like Twitter
killed all the third party clients
reddit's gonna do the same these guys
want to go public they're going to want
to own all they're going to want to you
own the user experience for all all
users of Reddit they're gonna kill you
and he's like no no no they've they said
like you know they said they're gonna be
fair
okay a couple months later it comes out
and they're like here's the pricing
it kills you and it takes into effect in
30 days and he's like what like First of
all ridiculous pricing second of all 30
days like I couldn't possibly try to
like change my app to maybe make less
requests to your server or like I
couldn't do anything in 30 days like
you're just gonna kill my whole business
and I took yearly subscriptions so I'm
not only on my app gonna die I'm gonna
have to refund like
250k to people who paid for a Year's
subscription because my app's no longer
going to work so he was in a world of
trouble so he contacts Reddit and he
does a call with the team from Reddit
and he records the call and after the
call
you can you can you're allowed to do
that in some states but not in every
state did he do it the right way dude a
neckbeard nation it's all good baby it's
uh it's all legal you're the little guy
fighting the big guy you can do whatever
you want yeah and so so he uh at first
he doesn't do anything with it then
Reddit comes out and says this guy's
crazy he's making outlandish claims he
tried to extort us for he asked for 10
million dollars
um in order to like keep supporting the
app we can't do business with this crazy
guy and they basically like kind of like
just you know slandered him a little bit
and he's like what are you talking about
that's not what I said and what do you
what did I say that was so outrageous
he's like here's the recording people
can listen to it themselves and decide
oh man did you listen to it I even
listen to the whole thing but there's a
part in there where he's like look like
did you sound reasonable yeah he sounds
reasonable he's basically like look um
you know obviously I'd love to just keep
going independent but you guys are
saying it's too expensive you want to
raise pricing that makes it untenable
for me but people like this app and
they're going to be upset when this app
goes down he's like you know you guys
bought Alien Blue Back in the day and
you made that the Reddit app like have
you considered just buying this app so
that you can like you don't have to pay
for all these extra you know it's not
some external part of you that you guys
but at least it lives on and like it's a
win-win solution potentially for for all
of us
and so he was like you know
um he said something like you're saying
this cost you this will cost me 20
million a year you're saying this costs
you tens of millions a year like you
could buy the whole thing for 10 million
dollars and that's you know six months
of my operating costs and you know like
it could work out that way and um Steve
Huffman on the call is like look like
you know I don't I don't appreciate the
threat type of thing he says something
about like that's a threat he goes wait
what's a what's a threat what do you
mean because the guy said something like
he goes um uh you know if if you don't
want all that like all this noise about
this like you could just do this and he
kind of took it as a threat like oh
you're threatening you're gonna make a
bunch of noise if we don't pay you 10
million dollars it goes no no I'm saying
um we have like you're saying I'm making
too many API calls so if you don't want
all this server noise for the API
requests you could just own it and just
use your internal systems to do it
instead and he's like oh sorry like okay
my bad uh I didn't realize you're
talking about API requests like I
apologize I didn't mean to like say that
you were threatening us you're saying
okay no problem like I just want to like
glad we're clear on that then later he
comes out and says he threatened us he's
like dude even on the call you apologize
saying saying uh sorry I misunderstood
you and then you took that out of
context and tried to make me sound like
a guy who's trying to profit out of this
um or like trying to make unreasonable
requests so anyways that cross so so
that was the other thing that sparked
drama now you've got leaked phone calls
you got the CEO calling a guy crazy he
said she said and so that raised the
profile of what was otherwise kind of a
small thing as the thing on Reddit small
things could turn into big things that's
like part of the beauty of Reddit and
that's what was happening here dude all
right first of all your energy is gonna
be sight this is a this is a great story
because I have a little more for you
here are you ready this is the part that
that's the background okay now let me
give you some foreground right let me
give you a little future future play
here okay
so four four play
um so Reddit may have forgot but this is
how Reddit started so Reddit started
because the the popular Forum side of
the day dig
made this big update and everybody hated
it and dig said screw you guys this is
better
and they said see ya and they went to
this little site called Reddit and
Reddit blew up and that's how Reddit
became what it is is that the Dig
fumbled the ball
released this anti you know this this
anti-user update and they usually
they're sticking it to the man yeah I
stuck it to the Man
well who's to say that doesn't happen
again so I have a little proposal uh
somebody should run with this idea I
bought this domain and I think somebody
should do this if not you know this is
what I would do if I was uh if I was a
little little younger and hungrier than
I am today so here's what I think
somebody should do I think that was the
perfect time the younger you the equally
conniving just a little bit more
ambitious you my T levels were a little
higher back there yeah I'm a mellowed
out dad now you know my daughter paints
my toenails I can't be doing all this
kind of stuff yeah if you if you woke up
at 10 A.M this morning and you wear a
hoodie all the time
you know this is for you neckbeard
Nation this is the call out okay so I
want you to just check out this little
website here so Sam I don't know if you
know what uh the CEO Steve's um handle
is on on Reddit do you know what his his
username is I used to yeah if you said
it I would remember it dark something uh
was it so SP easy and so I don't know I
just woke up this morning 6 a.m and I
just looked at GoDaddy and I just saw
that specialist.com was available and I
thought huh one cent for spezless.com so
I bought it I said what's specialist I
think it's it's Reddit without spez
would you like Reddit without Steve
well here's what we're gonna do well
we're gonna make a Reddit that's very
very very very very very similar look
into this website but with one
difference there's there's no steam
there's no Corporation that's gonna dude
the tagline needs to be same same but
different same same for different
exactly same same but different exactly
so here's uh Ben threw this up while we
were talking because I gave him a rant
this morning I was like dude here's what
someone should do and I think he just
bought he told me right before we went
on there he goes I'm gonna buy the
domain I'm gonna put it up so he goes um
it says I love Reddit I just don't like
don't like spez uh somebody create a
newsletter new Reddit it's called
specialist it's read it without Steve uh
here's the master plan it'll be very
very very similar website to Reddit
um it's going to be a non-profit and any
Revenue that it makes will get funneled
back into the communities or moderators
um because this blackout like this this
48-hour protest that they said
it's cool it's gonna get headlines but
Reddit really doesn't care they're gonna
lose about three million dollars by
being down for two days
and then they're just gonna move on with
life and the the protesters made a big
error which is they said how long they
would protest for they said the pain
will stop at 48 hours so all red has to
do is just ignore it for 48 hours uh
they're gonna keep doing what they want
so when you're when your voice doesn't
work you gotta exit and uh so here's
here's a little little exit boat for you
it's uh it's basically Reddit without
the [__] and um there's a little
email signup box so if a million people
sign up
then uh who knows maybe we can create
something here and so you know why do
this as a non-profit
your voice already rich we don't need it
we don't need to make a profit on this
we just create this for fun because it's
fun to to see something burned down I
don't even have a problem with CFO by
the way I think he's you know I like
Steve smart guy uh I think he's he's
fair in his opinion but also this is the
internet and in the internet you you
really gotta know who you're pissing off
and I think he's pissed off too many
people with this move I can't believe
that nobody's making the alternative to
this uh the people that are trying to
make Alternatives they're all trying to
do it so different
you don't want to do different it needs
to look almost exactly the same change
the shade of red by like two hex you
know like little hex color over to the
right and then uh it needs to be the
same site with the same structure
everything's the same except for who
decides what happens so how the money
flows and if you just change that you
could do this as a non-profit thing and
I think it would be uh very entertaining
in lieu of your morning cup of coffee
this morning you had a cup of rage and I
and I and I dig it dudes first of all a
few beautiful things
neckbeard nation that was nice right
that's our new that's our fan base so we
hired this woman to help us with some
T-shirts if she's listening uh she dude
this lady but hilarious hilarious thing
you did so listen to this this woman
this woman sent me this beautiful uh
remember you say the whole thing what
does she do so you get something in the
mail I get this thing in the mail and
it's like this beautiful like 10 or 20
Page outline it's clever and it says
what she's going to do for us to make
t-shirts is it beautiful it looks like a
giant giant PowerPoint deck that was
just printed out because she knows like
he might not click the link so let me
just print the PowerPoint out on white
and black you know paper and just put it
in an envelope for him it's beautiful
like when you see like a netbeard guy
doing very neck beard thing where you're
like I'm just happy this exists this is
a beautiful display
in that it's a beautiful it wasn't
physically beautiful but it was very it
was it was very clever and she said you
can reach me at my first thought at
gmail.com or something like that or yeah
right yeah t-h-o-t thought which stands
for that hoe over there and or she said
you can just DM me on my first thought
and so I talked to her and I was like
this is awesome let's do something we'll
work together it worked I email her with
you on the line and I go
I think I said dearesta or come on
and she was like great I mean by the way
uh you should look up my thought means
and I was like I know what it means I
thought that you you said it wanted to
because yeah you said it first to be
that was your Twitter handle I don't I'm
not trying to disrespect you you said it
not me I'm just repeating I'm just
playing the game here
by the way the funniest thing is you go
all right thought let's do this yes
and she was like I don't think you know
what thought means otherwise you
wouldn't have called me that she goes
LMAO at being addressed as my first
thought in your email Urban Dictionary
below for your amusement
yeah and I immediately replied I was
like I'm sorry I thought I thought I
thought this was a [__] uh you're right
I'll call you your real name my
apologies
so we didn't get off to the doctor a
great start right away all right let's
do this
so dear thought we're gonna uh this is
why we only have four female listeners
because this type of behavior I was
trying to I I you know I was trying to
relate I was trying to like show that I
read yeah it didn't work out well yeah
it's like when you hear hear someone
call their friend they're like yo Nikki
and you're like what's up Nikki and
they're like it's Nicholas okay just
because he
uh I was in uh LA this weekend and I
went to like the La Tech week saying we
went to this event and there was like
300 people and I'm not exaggerating I
had 30 people of like the 300 people
come up to me and like say like hey love
MFM I'm a total man and so two episodes
ago or one episodes ago Sean came up
with this idea of this total man we got
a lot of flack for it I don't know if
you saw it but people loved it in
general and I had literally 20 or 30
people like in a row come up be like
dude I'm the total Man by the way you're
doing it wrong it's not total man with
like a space in between because then
it's like yo I'm I'm the total man it's
I'm a total man it's like one word it's
like it's a it's a thing you're a noun
it's a different type of noun you got
you got you know mammals you got humans
and you got total man it's just like a
separate species get rid of the space
it's cleaner I got you yeah and uh so
total man that that that's a hit I think
neckbeard Nation with you being the
mayor I mean that or you being the
president that that that's that's our
new that's the new thing
we did it we got a new thing uh yeah
totally agree
um question which side are you on I
think I'm team Reddit on this one but
they screwed up they shouldn't have done
it this way in the first place uh you
know their Venture Capital company
they've got hundreds of employees
probably thousands at this point they
they fumbled the bag here not on the pr
press or PR front which they did but
like letting this get out of hand the
way it has in the first place I mean you
gotta you gotta pay the bills why are
they what are they doing letting people
build build the stuff on on their land
right you know what I mean yeah I I get
where they're coming from I think they
uh like many tech companies fumbled the
communication and execution
um but I'm also horrid at that so you
know I would have done this twice as bad
if I was in their position because I'm
always like I'm a very much ripped ended
off type of person and also like
because I'm
very far on the spectrum of not easily
offended like it takes a lot to make me
feel like mad or upset I severely
underestimate how easily I can make
other people mad or upset and so uh I I
get their position
um I think you know most likely unless
unless Bezos becomes a thing they're
just gonna be like cool nice protest we
hear you we'll take you into account in
the future
continue using Reddit you know like life
will just go on and nothing bad will
happen from this unless literally
somebody seizes The Narrative that's the
thing there's a narrative right now and
somebody could come in and they could
surf that momentum on the narrative
though we are the thing that's hard Uber
had the same thing do you remember when
it was trending delete Uber like I think
these things come and go like this
happened in the crypto World crypto
world is like the most like ruthless
it's like just like knife fighting in
the streets and so openc had some policy
issue or some change I don't remember
what it was it was like fee change or
something why did it get people get mad
at Open Sea when they I forget what it
was they changed something
yeah they changed like the royalty take
rate or something where's podcasting
etiquette ever to ask the guy in the
room who's sitting like 10 feet behind
you with no mic or headphones to ask him
have you seen Joe Rogan Joe Rogan does
it anyone can do it
um so basically open C which was the big
nft Marketplace by far the dominant 100
market share type of thing
um change something in their policy
people didn't like it and literally like
in like a 48 hour period somebody spun
up a competitor and they did what was
called a vampire attack which was they
in crypto you could do this thing where
you could be like okay who are all the
Wallets on that use openc I can find
them they're all public that I can
airdrop them tokens that say if you come
over to our platform and claim them
create your account here you get free
tokens and people are like token might
be worth something and so they just like
they basically like vampire attack they
just suck the blood out of one network
to another and this happened several
times in crypto where they've basically
tried to do this now it's not always 100
successful but to go from you didn't
even exist to like a million to two
million users with like a shot at hey if
you deliver a dope user experience you
know this can work you know that's like
better than nothing and so in crypto
this has happened a couple times a
couple of the like defy tools have had
this app before oh we don't like your
policy we're gonna Fork your source code
rename it and uh we're gonna incentivize
all the major players on yours to come
over here and get like a bonus token if
they if they come claim their thing here
which builds the momentum in the
narrative
well I don't I mean like your energy I
don't know how to like one-up you here
uh you know like they say when you're
like supposed to like meet people you're
supposed to match their energy
uh to like make them feel comfortable I
don't know what to say I don't feel like
I feel like I feel like we're going to a
monster truck rally like Sunday Sunday
like you're a Gravedigger right now I'm
just in the stands trying to keep up
with ear plugs you know what I mean but
they said they said that's so awful how
do you even remember or know that that's
like they're radio ads right yeah
Monster Jam have you been to a monster
truck rally in the last 700 days is the
pope Catholic of course I have yeah I
would go to monster truck all the time
I've gone like five or six times dude
they do backflips now I'm not not gonna
go see a big ass truck do a backflip
um all right let me talk to you about
something that you actually are know
more than me about I think because
you're friends with them yeah and then I
want to talk about that's a lot of stuff
okay
I want to talk about the second thing
about milk Road and and nothing and
we'll leave time for that so uh
turpentine is that what it's called the
turpentine big time yeah uh so basically
this guy named Eric tornberg he's been
in the game for a while he's just done a
bunch of stuff on the internet including
founding a company called on Deck
he launched this new thing called
turpentine it was very nice he gave us a
little shout out uh but basically what I
believe it to be is just a podcast
Network for business content
particularly some type of like startup B
related stuff so there's like one on
media yeah yeah Tech there's one on
media I think there's one on on fintech
a few other things and he announced it
have you seen this what what am I
missing yeah I've seen this uh so Eric
tornberg's behind this Eric's awesome
guy
um did he talk to you about this before
he did it because I feel like if I was
going to do something like this
you're my phone a friend right no you
didn't talk to me you're my phone a
friend on that I've never talked to him
oh you never talk so you don't know each
other that well okay gotcha
um because he's on our like friend group
I guess um okay so I'm curious what your
take is on this because I think you know
a lot about this I have a strong opinion
but I want you to explain it I mean I
think you said it well he's trying to
create like what uh I would say the
easiest analog is like the ringer so the
ringer was started by Bill Simmons so
kind of like famous notable guy in the
in the sports journalism landscape
basically was like I'm gonna create a
network of sports podcasts I'll have my
show I'll have this guy do NBA I'll have
this guy do NFL I'll have this guy do
um you know pop culture I'll have this
guy do whatever and so they created a
network of podcasts ended up selling it
to Spotify for a few hundred million
dollars 200 200 something million
dollars and um really that was mostly
because Bill had the number one sports
podcast and he's like very influential
in Spotify had a strategy there so
um Eric's trying to do that for Tech so
he's like how do I be the ringer or how
do I be Barstool but for the tech
industry can I basically create uh like
intellectual entertaining but also
highly intellectual conversations about
things that people care about
um
in Tech and then he's looking for shows
so like basically if we were you know
not the badasses that we were we could
be like hey let's join turbo time we're
gonna get their back office we're gonna
get them helping us sell ads we're gonna
get like you know help with production
and we'll get cross-promoted
um amongst
um you know their their Network it's
very similar to like work week which
we've talked about on here before or
group's doing this kind of with like
newsletters and um turpentine is trying
to do this with uh podcast plus
newsletters plus other things that's
kind of the thing it says his tagline is
where experts talk so it's a network
podcast covering Tech business culture
and trans that are driving the future
and he's got I think three or four shows
right now oh looks like maybe five
three that he's doing and then uh a
couple that other people are doing but
they're all like very like fancy
schmancy like the cognitive Revolution
um you know media Empires Moment of Zen
and so they're they're kind of like I
would say highbrow compared to
what most podcasts are yeah so here's my
opinion
um I don't think anyone that you
mentioned or anyone out there is really
doing it perfectly but
this is beautifully done uh you go to
his website wow I thought you were going
to be anti you're pretty anti-most media
things no oh no it's gonna come it's
gonna come uh you're doing you're doing
that sandwich thing yeah yeah
[Laughter]
sandwiches always have it's not it's not
I love your logo hate everything else
like a sandwich is not meat cheese bread
it's bread meat cheese bread okay you
gotta it begins at it and it ends with
that no I I do like it so here's the
thing about these companies I think
if he doesn't raise money
I think it's awesome I think so long as
he doesn't raise money I think this
could be really really cool I think
owning this outright is amazing I think
that's really cool I think when I go to
his website I think he borderline like
if it was done a little bit the other
way it would be really douchey but the
way that he's done it it's actually
quite awesome like for example he quotes
Pablo Picasso and
you know that could go either way that
can go either way he went the right way
I think when you go to the website I
think the name is nice it's all like
pretty slick it's upscale it actually
looks really good I think that if you if
you if you did that a little bit
differently it would not work but he's
done like what's the what's the quote
for Pablo Picasso on there do you see it
uh yeah it says when art critics to get
together
they talk about form and structure and
meaning when artists get together they
talk about where you can buy cheap
turpentine
cool I think that's cool I think it's
cool and it's got a nice little picture
of Pablo I think it's awesome yeah uh
dude so on my next company I'm gonna get
a quote from Benny Blanco
it's Pablo Picasso I'm ready Blanco
we can do Bugs Bunny next too I mean I
think it's good man I think it's good
branding so my opinion is I think it's
cool if you own it I think it's cool if
so I don't know if you know this you
probably don't because who cares but
business insiders writer the writers are
on strike do you know that yes well a
lot of like isn't Hollywood also on
strike right now I think they're totally
unrelated other than maybe they inspired
each other I think there was like a
contract up and uh Insider formed at
Union or something like that and they
are protesting and they're doing this
thing called a digital
PICC line I guess it's called where a
digital picket line where they're like
telling all the customers like not to
click on Business Insider links now uh
which is crazy I mean someone who
follows a Business Insider journalist is
probably not also someone reading
Business Insider I would imagine so I I
don't know if that's gonna go well but
if you have to if so if you're gonna
start a media company
I think you have to be incredibly
careful not to hire folks who will
unionize I think that is actually an
existential crisis to a lot of media
companies right now
um and I think that's like a real so if
you're so here's the takeaways I think a
it's awesome so you're going to do this
I think it's cool I think you should own
the whole thing B look out for Union
types C him going B to B that's 100 the
way to go and I want to give you an
example but is this B2B I don't think
this is B2B what makes you say this I
think he just has uh I think he has uh
probably he's probably going for like
high-end customers more so than b to B
right yeah but your ad sales people can
spend that nicely to Salesforce uh like
it's not like True Crime you know what I
mean it's borderline it's kissing
cousins with the with the B2B uh real
B2B it's close but let me give you an
example of a real b2b1
yeah it's Bish
um have you heard by the way did you see
that guy who's gonna getting in trouble
his name is George Santos he's like
clearly I think he's like from South
America but he was um I'm gonna butcher
it but he was some type of elected
official out of Long Island and uh he's
getting in trouble because he did a
bunch of fraudish stuff I think but one
thing that's funny is he told everyone
he was Jewish and he goes well I didn't
say I was Jewish I said I was Jewish
like
I'm friends with the Jews I was Jew itch
like you know like uh I'm buddies with
them have you not seen it yet all time
all time excuse he like stole 500 000 so
he's actually a crook but like the
funniest part he goes I'm Jewish and you
look at him and he's uh uh like from
Brazil or something like what uh so
that's pretty funny but uh anyway I
think that instead of going B to be ish
you gotta go all the way
I can't find this client info have you
heard of HubSpot HubSpot is a CRM
platform so it shares its data across
every application every team can stay
aligned no out of sync spreadsheets or
dueling databases HubSpot grow better
have you heard of Aging media no
okay so type in aging media it started
by this guy named John John's a member
of Hampton but everything I'm actually
about to say I just kind of stole from a
similar web but I have heard some rumors
about them but basically if you go to
aging media what's what what's the uh
you've been on his Hampton application
we're here to write his Revenue profits
uh names of all his children and social
security number you may you may have
some info on this please
I just clicked similar web on their site
no info so I know you ain't getting [__]
from similar web right now oh yeah yeah
so here's why here's I'm gonna explain
it to you but you know listen aging
media is their like corporate website so
what's it say they have like their
brands like senior housing news hospice
news skilled nursing news that sort of
thing those happen so what what what's
the what's that meta tag on there is it
like uh nursing home profession or yeah
media for the senior care industry yeah
so click like one of their websites and
you can go to similar web each website
only has something like 50 000 visits I
believe it's like it's like not a lot
but they're doing something like 12 or
11 million dollars a year Revenue and
like three or four million dollars a
year in profit and this is a B2B
hardcore B2B site they make their money
through Legion so basically I imagine
they'll do like a webinar or something
and if you like are in the nursing home
industry you give them information they
also have ads and I think I don't know
if I have podcasts but they do have
newsletters on their site this is a
hardcore B2B this is yeah
and I love it I love it I love this you
just did this guy such a disservice by
seeking for for four to forty copycats
on them if I'm talking about how you
know business this is on here well no so
like the idea listen to this podcast so
like if Sam or Shawn say the n-word I
don't mean the n-word I mean newsletters
if they say this is a good newsletter
business the instant copy cop hats bro
they're instantly looking for a new
newsletter to club no no no I apologize
and on behalf of whoever this guy is
in the Hampton I go hey don't tell me
anything but it just can I talk about
your company and I I said here's what I
see on similar way he didn't know what
he was saying yes to no hey I got
permission I go here's here's what I see
on similar web this is what I'm gonna
say are you cool with it and he gave me
a thumbs up like literally a thumbs up
emoji that's how I roll I get that emoji
we're good
um That's a hardcore B2B media company
so anyway my point with this turpentine
thing I think it's cool I like it I
think it's cool I hope he pulls it off
I've thought about doing this idea
actually in the past I ruled it out for
a bunch of reasons but that doesn't mean
it doesn't mean somebody else can't do
it I think I think it'd be great to do
it takes a lot of energy and I'm totally
with you that I hope you didn't raise
money he's in his tweet thing uh
announcing it he didn't he didn't say
like so happy to have Marc Anthony
recent investing in this so so I think
there is uh I think there's probably a
good chance he raised money but
he didn't raise okay he didn't raise
money so so I hope he is taking it that
way well you probably learned from uh
from his other company on Deck like
that's another company where I think
they raised a hundred plus million I
forget but I think the valuation was 500
million dollars so I don't know how much
they raised but I imagine it was the
United figures that's another company
where it's like
that could be cool if you don't raise
money basically screwing up your cap
table is like one of the only mistakes
in business that you can't really make
up for
um speaking of screwing up your money
can I tell you what I did post milk road
with the with the money that we made
well I do know that you sent me a text I
I have to go look at when that came and
you said I've sold all my equities I
think it's gonna go to the I think the
Market's going down and since then do
you've it's double it's about double
yeah a lot of so I know you did that
with your money so what else did you say
sorry about my next best decision yeah
what else did he do besides not make
money off your money for the record for
the record uh
I've actually I would be about even from
where I was with my equities on that
because I kept well I kept a portion of
it but I also uh the stuff I sold has
not doubled you just look at HubSpot
stock because you're like I got upside
so you're like HubSpot is the market
how's that is not the market exactly so
uh so I'll tell you that so let me um
let me tell you about what I did so we
got this money so we sell milk Road
now this cash hitting a bank account
got a couple options so it's like do we
just buy treasury bills make four
percent on that uh what bank do you use
what bank did I use what do you mean you
use a Chase or one of the other ones
security breach I'm not there's no
upside and answer this question did you
use one of the ones you you were using
one of the ones that got screwed up no
no no I didn't use Silicon Valley Bank
no so
money's sitting there as I could buy
treasury bills uh no that's too boring
um could
do what Sam does I could just index into
the stock market oh that's reasonable
but like you know I think uh seems like
we're coming off of a of a 13 year old
bull market
um don't really need to to put this the
full amount in right now let me just
kind of wait and see what happens there
is there something is there something
that can do better than the eight
percent uh that I might be able to get
on that I thought well should I just
invest it in a new company we start uh I
don't know maybe if we have a great idea
we'll do that but but let me just let me
not do that
and so I started doing this process
where I was like
can I I work backwards so basically like
can I get 30 a year compounding and 30 a
year sounds like a high number but we
have a few friends who have done it and
the way that they've done it has been
through buying private companies so they
buy businesses and they own Andrew
Wilkinson I think is the one that most
people who listen to this pod will know
because he's been on a bunch of times
and talked about this how they built
Tiny from a few million dollars into you
know 500 million dollars by doing this
sort of 30 40 compounding over over time
the uh tiny annual report we'll have to
talk about it next time yeah I I read
this into a letter um yeah so so and we
have a few other friends that have been
doing this as well uh that are less
public about it so I said okay well let
me do that I said but I don't want to
buy these companies and operate them so
I thought
what if I bought 30 Stakes so sort of
like uh can I buy a minority position in
companies so that they keep running them
but I give them Capital so basically
like the founder oftentimes was like not
taking a lot off the table or they were
kind of always worried like should I put
this in my pocket and spend this well I
don't know what if the company needs it
um even if a profitable they were kind
of worried about that so say here let me
give him some money and then could I
help them grow and so I went through
this exercise I don't think I've told
you about any of these but I talked to
about 25 companies in the last I want to
say six months to every company that you
talk to DMS me and they say something of
a variety of I was talking to Sean and
now we're not talking anymore but they
like they like messaged me to like talk
to you and I just ignore it
yeah you're like the wing man who
refuses to win you you don't have to
tell me which companies I already know
probably half of them my funnel was this
I was just doing a review of this I
thought it was kind of interesting so
talk to about 20 24 companies I think
um got serious I like did like did
diligence I would say talk to means like
uh talk to me it's like I was interested
you know obviously we looked at a little
bit more than that but talk to was like
oh this could be interesting maybe you
could kind of squint and see a
possibility then got into kind of like
more serious talks and either negotiated
numbers or diligence with about nine
uh got to a Loi stage with three or four
and ended up doing one deal and the last
I want to say six months post uh post
sale
and so this ranged from everything from
um so newsletter businesses only fans
businesses Journal apps virtual events
bookkeeping companies merch companies
and then a bunch of random stuff that I
know nothing about that were like oh
that sounds interesting like uh some
company that like does something called
laser peening on machines to make the
parts last longer and their clients are
like bowing and stuff like that or um
autism clinics that seem to make a ton
of money but I'm like okay I don't
really know how I would add any value to
this and uh in each one I was like all
right can I find a good operator where I
can acquire minority stake of the
business at a good deal and I could help
them grow and ideally they're the
category winner for for what they do and
so that was kind of like my process I
want to before I tell you about the deal
that we ended up doing I want to hear
any uh any thoughts or questions on my
my Approach here because there's a bunch
of learnings yeah there's no way you're
gonna get 30 for that long right do you
actually think that's possible what do
you mean for that long that long between
I don't I mean I don't know anything
about markets I haven't read like a
Warren Buffett biography but like what's
he compound at every year oh oh okay
yeah he's been at 20 for like 50 years
or something okay but if he but if you
got it he's putting billions and
billions of dollars to work and uh
that's very different right okay I think
that's smart do you think you're gonna
enjoy this I think you'll enjoy it right
I'm not sure so this was a test
basically to see like is this fun to do
it's definitely fun on the learning side
uh now that we made the first
acquisition or the first I kind of I
would say not an acquisition like kind
of minority investment
um and it's different than startups like
we've done startup investing startup
investing is very very different startup
investing is you look at a business
you're trying to figure out is this are
these three dudes in this bedroom gonna
be able to build like a multi-billion
dollar company right like is this
husband and wife couple going to be able
to pull off this this gargantuan exit
and like kind of right now they have
usually nothing just an idea a product
maybe a little bit it's way more of a
lottery it's a lottery and you put put
in a hundred thousand dollars and then
you do that with 40 companies and you
know that 38 of the companies are going
to be kind of like just a write-off or
cost of doing business and two or three
of those those 30 or 40 companies are
going to be your winners but hopefully
they're winning at 100x or a thousand
Acts or more uh returns and so it's very
Lottery like and you you spend very
little time with them so you're not like
um they don't want you advising them
you answer questions when they call you
could proactively nudge them a little
bit but you're mostly hands off I would
say Angel Investing whereas if you buy
15 20 25 30 of a business uh you're a
little more involved um you know you
care a little more active these
businesses are not like All or Nothing
businesses they're like oh this is
already a good business it's profitable
and it's already growing so the question
is can we accelerate the growth right so
like the one business we bought is I
don't know super profitable it makes
millions of dollars a year in profits
it's uh you know more than 50 margins
and
um you know we were able to buy a piece
of that and I think that uh that's just
so different than every startup
investment I had ever done you know it's
probably not going to become a
multi-billion Dollar business I would
almost guarantee that but it doesn't
need to it's not supposed to it's a cash
flow business and so isn't it funny how
you have mocked me for like the last
eight years about my slow and steady
approach and now you're you know look
you're still at first it was like
laughing at eight percent I'm going for
10x every year or whatever right now
it's it's coming down now 30 is really
attractive which I agree that is really
attractive before you know it you're
gonna say no dude that's that's not true
even in a startup fund even when you
have your winners that become billion
dollar companies the overall fund like a
great fund is doing 30 irr or twenty
percent
it's still the same boring
no it's not I I reject that I reject
that premise I would say you used to
make a live streaming app and now you're
looking at uh a company that sells parts
to Boeing
but cash flow is always interesting it's
always been interesting
um and now it's more interesting than it
was in the past I really didn't I really
didn't have a lot of exposure to these
types of business I lived in San
Francisco you say cash flow and people
think you're talking about like you know
like a leaky faucet like nobody knows
what the hell the hell that means and so
uh once I
just started doing this podcast we got a
lot more exposure to like most people
listen to this podcast are entrepreneurs
all around the world and so when they
reach out about their business it's like
oh this guy in Minnesota with this you
know marketing agency that does this per
year or this person sells parts and this
person does whatever uh you know they're
rolling up bookkeeping services and so
you you learn about different types of
businesses more through this and uh so
I've been getting my like MBA on on
non-silicon Valley businesses look the
cool thing is is that you know we
research stuff and like if I really dive
deep into a topic I'll research it for
eight hours and I that's not enough to
make an investment but it's enough that
I say to myself oh wow this space is
really intriguing you know I could see
myself doing this you're doing that but
instead of eight hours you're doing
weeks and so It's oddly in the similar
vein a bit uh of course you have to do
more due diligence and actually look at
the numbers and get to know the people
but yeah it's like getting used to the
space so the most interesting thing is
what happened between the four deals
that we signed Lois on and the one that
we closed and I'll try to do this
without giving away any info about the
companies that we didn't do the deal
with uh I could talk about the one we
did but I can't talk about the one we
didn't
um but the things I though the reasons
that the mistakes that we were making
along the way here's here's trap number
one that we already experienced
um
I can fix him
like the classic girlfriend mistake like
yeah he you know he sucks but maybe I
could fix him it's basically like maybe
I can fix this business
and when you do this minority investing
you're not the majority you're not going
to be able to fix anything and so that
was uh you know trap number one was
getting really far down the road with
the business that I thought had a ton of
potential but for finally realizing I'm
not going to be the one to fix it and
fixing it is the wrong approach to doing
going into a business like this that was
mistake one
mistake two was
I can totally I can totally uh see this
working
but working at a small scale and so you
have to remember basically like as you
play the game it's kind of like this is
how I felt about like your Airbnb which
is like you do one Airbnb that's you
basically can't do one Airbnb you can
only do one as a test to see if you want
to do a bunch one Airbnb is like
a bunch of headache without the size of
the prize being big enough and so we had
looked at one business that was like
yeah which is what I have by the way
yeah yeah we all make this this mistake
but I think you were at least looking at
it the right way where you were like
maybe I could do a bunch of these you
talked to people that had 50 of these in
their portfolio and you have to do one
to know if you want to do 50. and so we
got really far down the road with this
one that like if it all worked it's like
dude we could be making
two hundred thousand dollars a year off
this it's like wait what are we doing
what why are we doing this like yeah
it's a great deal and it's highly likely
to work but it's highly likely to be
very small and like not worth the Mind
share of even doing this and so we
pulled out on that one the one that we
did was basically uh a company people
probably know
so it was in a cat so this one was not
are you gonna name it yeah yeah it's
official so we first looked at the
category so I was super bullish on
companies that let you hire
internationally so specifically like how
to hire the Philippines and laddam and
you know this why were you interested in
that what inside like kind of scar
tissue like dude you came to my office I
remember you you came to my office in
San Francisco when I was doing bibo and
you're like what's your burn rate which
again is like a question nobody asks
somebody else out loud it's like you
know that's like asking somebody that's
asking a woman their weight like ask a
Founder their burn rate and see how they
feel in my head I was like that's bubbly
you had a bubbly burn man and I was like
three million a year and that's what we
were we were basically a startup that
was burning three million a year
pre-product Market fit because that's
what it cost we had we basically had a
team of Engineers so we had like you
know I don't know 10 a month
a month 2004 I think we were doing like
240 000 a month in burnt so you get like
and that's netburn does that mean no
does that assume no Revenue
um we had revenue from one of our
projects but like no I was just saying
like the overall bill so um
so we basically you hire 10 people that
are 200 000 each you're doing 2 million
plus you pay rent plus you have your
Cloud bills especially whatever else and
uh
so that was really expensive and those
were all Silicon Valley engineers and
they were below market so those people
if they were working for us for 200k
they could have been making 400 500k at
Facebook but they wanted to be a part of
a startup
so I did that and it was very stressful
to have a very high burn rate uh for a
company like I just didn't like it but I
didn't know any better at the time and
then afterwards as I got a little more
Savvy like with our Ecom biz
we'll do probably
somewhere but like a little under 20
million this year in Revenue
uh were profitable because 65 of our
team is overseas so we have our like our
our data analysis person Argentina our
designer India our customer service
Philippines are the person who's running
our whole wholesale Channel like built
it from scratch it did not exist and now
it's like a new Revenue unit in the
Philippines and we did the same thing
with milk road we were profitable milk
Road from day one like I remember coming
to your office at the hustle and you had
like I don't know 15 people running
around there in San Francisco and like
that's a bunch of San Francisco issues
they have to go home and pay six
thousand dollar rent so you got to pay
them money and for us we had one person
in the US for milk Road and we had
everybody else in the Philippines and so
it was again lean mean profitable
machine and I was like oh
um not just is this cost savings like if
you hire some of the Philippines they're
basically 10 times cheaper than the US
so like you know you can hire somebody
in the Philippines for a thousand
dollars a month so 12 000 in a year that
same person the US will cost you 80 to
120k
um and these are skilled people like in
Latin like the guy we have doing our
data stuff he's like he's got his MBA
like they're these are Highly Educated
highly you know he's like a wizard with
like you know power bi and looker and
all these like data tools that I
couldn't even do you get to know yeah
yeah of course I'm talking to them all
the time the one good thing is
especially with the Philippines uh this
sounds terrible but I'm gonna say it
anyways because it's honest
um
I hate managing people and I love hiring
people in the Philippines because they
need so little management like I uh why
does that sound horrible what did I miss
there because I think what people want
is for you to be like I'm a good manager
and I talk to my people and I'm like
dude it's [__] great I only talk like
for example my assistant I only talked
to her on Fridays
I mean or like it's great they don't
want one-on-ones and like career
trajectory coaching and they don't want
like like the same like in San Francisco
I had let's say I have eight direct
reports that's eight weekly one-on-ones
I had to do yes well dude I've had
that's essentially eight hours out of
the 160 hours a week that you know that
that I have that I'm like uh you know
I'm spending doing basically like
touchy-feely stuff which is fine I
understand it but it's really nice when
you don't have to do that because it's
not the Baseline expectation there's a
bunch of roles where you don't want
someone who's entirely ambitious like
with totally an assistant it's like you
don't want someone that's like no I
don't want to give you all these other
opportunities I want you to be great at
this thing and not bail like I don't
this is what I need this is the tool
that I need and I want you to be that I
don't want to have to promote you tons
and tons of times I've hired a couple of
people uh for like our hold code
basically
um and they're they're cooled or they
live in San Francisco they're awesome
they're super motivated to work with me
I'm like great what do you want like I
want to be you out of like wait what and
then I'm like cool like you know someday
they're like yeah but I'm also spinning
up my own newsletter my own podcast my
own investment arm like I'm like okay
well like that's great you could do that
but you that makes for kind of a shitty
person to hire onto my team because like
part of being on this team is being down
for our mission not like your own
mission necessarily and I totally get if
you want to go to your own mission but
you got to go do that on your own don't
get you don't get to have both
um you know at the same exact time you
can do one and get mentored for a bit
and then go do your own but you can't do
it at the exact same time and so it has
been very nice to have people that are
just like they CL like literally like
our management style is they log in they
say logging in here's what I'm doing
today
if you have any adjustments to you you
say something if not you just don't say
anything at the end they say long enough
here's what I got done today here's
everything I did here's the files here's
the here's the info login off so how
much are you spending you know on on
these on these folks
I mean dude I have like
in my own companies probably almost 15
to 20 people that are international now
and so and what's the average salary
um it ranges so like on the low end uh
800 I think about it in months monthly
because that's like when I push payroll
that's what it says so like you know 800
a month would be the low end and that's
how you'll say most common so that's a
customer support personal assistant
things like that could be that low and
then uh the higher rolls will be like
twenty five hundred to three thousand
and then there's one guy who's just
amazing and I've promoted him up twice
now and now he gets paid like a US
employee because he makes the impact of
somebody who's like driving a ton of
growth so I'm like oh great like you
keep getting rewarded you're at some
point you break break through where
you're if you're driving growth you get
rewarded for driving correct and you
also I got an email you you have a
course on this now too
I have a course on the personal
assistant side yeah I just created it's
not even a course actually it's just uh
I don't like I don't go and teach it
it's just a system it's like yo
basically the best hire I made this year
was I hired my personal assistant and I
had thought
okay personal assistant is uh
uh you know personal assistants like for
rich people for like Mega it's like for
Jeff Bezos it's like Mega busy make a
rich and uh and also was like I don't
wanna have to tell somebody what to do
all the time like that sounds like its
own pain in the ass to come up with [__]
to do
and then I heard a few friends talk
about theirs and I was like maybe I'm
wrong let me open my mind to the
possibility that I'm wrong about this
three people tell me three people that I
trust tell me that it's like been a huge
game changer for them let me just send
it to me I want to use it
I basically created the whole thing last
week and I was like here's my system so
for example like here's my my email
system like I used to be terrible with
email and now my email system is like
super organized on top of [__] here's
exactly what I do here's the exact scope
of work here's how here's how it works I
just texted Ben I go I said send it to
me yeah uh and so and yeah by the way
there's a like a a funny offer we did
with it but I'll explain the copy that
we ended up investing in so I looked at
all the ways you could do this I've done
all of them so you can hire direct if
you want to hire somebody International
you can basically have three options you
hire direct so you hire somebody on like
a job board
upwork online job something like that
upside it's basically free you just pay
the software subscription like in our 99
bucks a month so you know you pay a
thousand dollars for the year to be to
be a pro member on there downside you
have to do all the hiring vetting
training sifting through candidates
yourself like you put up hey I need a
customer support person or a personal
assistant you're gonna get 200
applications I'm like good luck trying
to find somebody good
um you could also go on the high end and
use like a managed service so this is
things like um growth assistant or
Athena they're great they do the they do
the vetting for you but there's this
huge up charge so those guys charge you
three grand a month
for somebody that actually costs 800 a
month so you're paying you're paying 3x
the price or more
every single month forever that's how
big are those companies how big is
Athena I heard they're huge they're big
and they're big because this is like a
huge ARR thing for them and people don't
really know about it people don't really
realize like you didn't have to pay
triple the price every single month and
so that's like you know One path and but
they're good at what they do I've tried
them yeah I've tried a bunch of these
um the one I liked the best was the one
we ended up investing in which is
Shepard so people have probably heard of
Shepard before I think the URL support
shepard.com
why like Shepherd was it's kind of best
of both so they do the like filtering
screening background checks all that
stuff so basically you just say I want a
personal assistant they present you
three great candidates or they present
you five great candidates for you and
they're they're filtered they're checked
and they're basically like these are the
best of the best so they save you a [__]
ton of time which is like as any
business owner you kind of need that and
the other side you don't have to pay the
monthly up charge so they'll say great
here's you know you can make the hire
directly and all you pay is the one-time
finders fee for us having found you the
candidate and so it ends up being you
know
10 to 20 times cheaper than these other
ones in the long run because you just
paid you know the one-time finders fee
so I like that model the best I was like
long term I think this is the most
sustainable because if I'm making in my
business like I did 15 hires
internationally I want I don't want to
be paying like this bloated cost every
month from there on out nor do I want to
do that all that work myself so that was
the business we ended up investing in
um super excited the The Branding on
their website so it's support
shepherd.com yeah you have to be one of
the testimonials you need a testy on
there but uh
it looks good it's cute branding uh so
Marshall Haas is the guy who started it
Marshall I've known Marshall since 2012
maybe he's the type of guy who whenever
he does something it's awesome it looks
cool uh so like if you follow him on
Instagram on Twitter he's got
Showmanship he's got Showmanship he's
got the juice he's got the juice so
whenever like for example I think he
just bought a new house and I'm like
following the bill about us he also like
he likes cars so like I saw him like
redecorate his garage he owns like a
boutique hotel he did this like
e-commerce thing that was like super
simple and actually like a really good
like you know a successful successful
econ business that was just like it was
like a phone case and like you know it
was just that and like when Kobe came
out they came out with this little like
hook thing like your Captain Hook that
was like you can use this to open doors
without having to touch the knob like a
peasant I was like dude this guy's great
he just makes these like simple little
businesses and he runs all the reason he
did this is he ran his businesses using
international hiring as his like
Workforce so then he partnered with this
guy in the Philippines opened up a
office on the ground there with a bunch
of recruiters to do all the vetting
locally on the ground is he going to the
Philippines his business partner lives
there and is has the the office open
there so that's like how you that you
got to commit if you're going to do
these types of things and so he
basically partnered with the guy who's
doing that and that's how they created
Shepard and it started off just like you
know solving their own Niche but turns
out like a lot of people have have this
itch and so and myself included so uh so
if he I follow I I'm not used it but I
will I will use it I I would like to use
I'm literally I just texted Ben I really
actually want your course I want to
figure out how you do this because I
want this and maybe I'll use these guys
but if his business is going so well why
would he sell a portion to you like my
head is I'm greedy I'm like get the [__]
out of here because
I mean obviously we're gonna drive him a
little bit or a lot of bit of traffic in
the Pod will is that the only reason why
he would do this uh yeah basically they
don't spend any money on marketing
um at all and so the way that it spreads
is just Word of Mouth people coming back
and then the other one is like
entrepreneurs who have an audience
saying saying the word so they first did
this with Mick uh Huber and Nick Nichols
drove them a ton of business because
Nick uses it uh for all of his
businesses and so he when he talks about
it they get a bunch of uh they get a
bunch of traffic so I think he saw the
success of that and
um basically you know we have a large
audience now like through Twitter
through this pod through other things
and so there's obviously a benefit of I
don't know like the brand Association
like as well as like you know the the
ability to reach you know reach a large
audience that I think was appealing to
him and I bought in I didn't get free
shares right like I bought I bought into
the to the equity pool but I agree with
you when you have a really good business
you're always hesitant it has to be like
the right fit and so I think the other
benefit was he listens to the Pod and so
he's seen you know if you listen to this
you know how we think if you can agree
be like this person's great or this
person's an idiot you know if you want
to if you would want to do business with
them if you've listened to the Pod
regularly you you have a very good idea
there's no hiding our personalities on
this do they have a MFM like coupon code
is it coupon coupon so if you go to my
website if you go to seanbury.com remote
assistant basically here's what I got
them to do which is better than a coupon
thing so I was like all right if you
want to do the personal assistant thing
the way I did uh I was all right here's
my systems 250 bucks you get the whole
like all the templates all the thing or
whatever but I was like um I only want
to make money from people who don't take
action and so here's here's how it works
basically should just buy the course you
don't actually hire an assistant I keep
your money but if you actually go to
Shepard and you hire your assistant then
Shepard will give you 2x the money back
so basically you pay 250 you'll get 500
if you actually take the action and go
higher and I was like that's kind of a
no-brainer offer I was like Marshall we
got to do this like do this where if
people want their own assistant
and they actually go like take the
action and go forward with it pay them
back not just what they paid for the
system pay them double because uh like I
bet a bunch of people are just not gonna
take action but who cares like I want
the people who who will take action to
be rewarded for doing so and so that's a
pretty pretty sweet deal basically it's
like a you essentially get my system for
free plus you make an extra 250 if you
uh if you actually go go forward with it
and make your higher so first I want if
you're into this [__] I have no stake in
this by the way uh but go to support
Shepard I do want them to sign up
because here's what I want I want you to
report back and I want to hear if this
whole influencer buys companies thing
actually is good I wanna so I want I
want the results to be reported back in
like a month and so I am curious to see
like what the demand is I bet it's gonna
be quite good number two what I'm
curious to see is if you like this uh I
don't know if you're gonna like it or
not I can see going at 50 50 either way
so far how do you feel I mean look if
this deal works then this is like the
greatest thing I don't know this one is
a no but that's not the hard part this
is always easy this is already a
successful company I'm already religious
about hiring internationally anyways
personally in my own businesses it's
like I didn't have to be convinced that
this is a good idea like I already knew
there's a good idea the question was am
I going to start my own of these or
should I invest in one that's already
working that I like that I use and it's
like okay cool let me just do the second
one that seems like way less work you
know to do that so I think this one is
kind of a no-brainer in that it's kind
of a proven business I am a genuine
believer in it and whether we actually
drive extra traffic to them or not I
think it's it's sort of like
I don't know like obviously for them
they want that then and I would like
that too but for me it was already you
say it was already what percentage are
you is that too much to ask or to review
yeah I want to disclose that here
because I think you know it's their
business I don't wanna I don't want to
give that away too much but you know
it's a it's a good chunk I think do you
think they'll ever sell the company or
do you make your money just through
dividends yeah just dividends like it's
a profitable business
um it just pays out dividends like I got
our first dividend check yesterday it's
awesome
you did you got one already yeah it was
fantastic
this is going to be your See's Candy
maybe I mean if this works out that's
exciting I'm curious to see if you're
gonna like this because on one hand I
could actually see you loving this
because you get to spend time seeing how
things work and you get to use your
skill set which is content to tell
people about it like this segment that
we just did I'm actually interested I
want to keep talking about this just
because I want to hear the story about
it I think that's interesting and so
it's kind of a win-win in that regard
but I'm curious if you're going to enjoy
all the due diligence like when I talk
to Andrew Wilkinson he actually I don't
think does a lot of the due diligence
he's got a team to do right if you are
able to pull that off I think you'll be
in a win situation
um so as long as you like like doing
that yeah I'm gonna try with two or
three this one I knew was on a slam dunk
because I'm just like just a total
believer in it what's gonna be
interesting is what happens with
ones that aren't like perfectly in my
zone of like I get it I used it I
believe in it like it's like this one
was like Bullseye I don't expect every
business to be exactly Bullseye so the
question is what happens when it's not
exactly is it still fun do I still
believe do I am I still willing to talk
about it like this one I'm willing to
talk about because I'm like I literally
wouldn't have my econ business work the
way it does or milk red worked the way
it did if I didn't use this strategy so
I'm like I could talk about that now
what happens when it's like one degree
separated from that am I still Gonna
Wanna to tell a story on it maybe it's
not even that interesting a story I'm
not gonna do it like I'm not gonna come
on this podcast and bore everybody with
like a story that's not that great so I
can't I can't commit to that yet but I
don't know if somebody wants me to buy
you know a minority taking their
business hit me up let's see let's see
what happens I'm gonna try two or three
of these and see see how it goes was
there anything uh that you learned
looking at the 24 other than what you
said about the uh
like fix me [__] like was there anything
any other Revelations not necessarily
about what they had wrong with them or
but maybe what they had to write with
them any commonalities between the
winners yeah uh yeah definitely I would
say that
the
um
the businesses that I was most
interested in were ones that had a clear
um
a clear sales model I would say
so
they knew how they were going to get
their customers now and in the future
and
um I don't want to say moat because it's
like you're just trying to be Warren
Buffett like it's not like something
they had a moat but they had you know
either recurring revenue or they had
something that was like they're they're
actually the category leader they're the
go-to leader and that there's some
reason why
they're not just going to get copied
into Oblivion by everybody else maybe
it's maybe they have operational
Advantage maybe they what's Shepherds I
mean I think branding is actually a
that separates them here I think they
look cool is there anything else yeah I
think Shepard's uh real Advantage is
that they're they picked a business
model that's actually more customer
friendly like I said So like
um if your two other options are spend a
bunch of time have a bunch of
uncertainty hire somebody unvetted
and you save a little bit of money or
pay a 3X monthly up charge like you're
kind of nuts to do the 3x monthly up
charge for a long period of time
especially if you're gonna hire multiple
roles eventually in your company like
it's just not a sustainable path so to
me support Shepherd's choice on the
business model separated them from the
current competitors now somebody else
could try to do it but what are they
gonna have to do they're gonna have to
go set up
boots on the ground in the Philippines
and in latam and really be good at you
know recruiting recruiters who are then
going to recruit the talent to actually
deliver on these roles and hire high
quality people because they they don't
really like the money's not made in your
first hire the money's made when you're
like you see the light and you come back
to them for your next six hires like
what I did with Ecom is like I started
with customer support and I was like
cool I need somebody to do inventory
forecasting people in the US really
expensive for that honey 140k for that
that role here could I find somebody
overseas that could do inventory
forecasting can I find somebody that
could do can run our Amazon uh ads can I
find somebody who could do wholesale as
a channel like can I find people that do
influencer like you start to be like oh
wait this isn't just about what it used
to be which was like va's equals
low-cost labor now it's like dude
they're pretty talented people that
could do these things they got three or
four years of experience doing that at
another company
and so you're able to just pluck from
the remote talent pool versus just your
local talent pool
dude I'm excited to see how this turns
out at Hampton do you guys have any
overseas people yet or no yeah yeah for
sure we have like the guy who made our
website is overseas and he's on staff we
have our accounting folks that who like
the they're called fuel Finance they're
overseas if you go to uh like we have
this whole back end thing built where
people can log in it was built by a guy
in Hong Kong
um yeah we have a ton of overseas and
Marshall's a member and so we're gonna
actually thinking about starting to use
them for some data analytics stuff so
yeah by the way like the fun is all a
lot of overseas when I was using uh for
are you coming a lot of you come people
use agencies I uh I'll hire an agency
and then they like they're like great
let's add can you add these three people
to slack and all of them by their names
yeah and I'm just like so like for
example uh design pickle I think is like
a 10 million dollar a year business to
basically like design unlimited designer
on demand uh we tried them out for a
little bit every single designer is in
the Philippines
um then I hired this email marketing guy
I was like oh you had to do our email
email marketing and flows he's based in
call Colorado every employee is in the
Philippines I was like okay that's
another one
um I hired a website a web dev shop yeah
owners in the US entire team is in India
uh you know another one that did the
entire thing in Ukraine and it's like
it's so funny that people are basically
this is now a business model is
basically like owner in the US does
sales fulfillment all done by it and
they're good I'm not even saying this
like a bad thing like they're talented
but I'm like wow this is a whole
business blueprint a template that they
could use which would basically like
make the margins work uh what are you
gonna go there when are you going when's
the Philippines yeah when's neckbeard
Nation going to the Philippines
we should host the next live pod there
do we have a following there I have no
idea uh unfortunately I don't think we
do I don't think they give a [__]
dude you got to go there
um I've been in the Philippines it's
awesome tonight and I've never been I'll
go tonight and tomorrow I'm taking a
15-hour road trip in my Tesla uh my
first time doing it we're gonna see if I
love it or hate it so I'm gonna report
back on Wednesday 15th hour you said
it normally takes 12 but you add three
hours for charging yeah I did a charging
road trip was horrible where are you
going from where are you going to what's
the distance uh Austin to St Louis
okay I'm gonna visit my family uh would
you get the x or the Y which one are you
doing X long distance 350 miles
is it a new one because the thing I
screwed up was the one I rented on turo
was like five years old and it just
needed charging every 90 minutes it was
an awful experience
well how fast you go I mean it's like
highway right so you're going like
whatever 75 miles an hour I mean I speed
usually is I mean I'll go 85 or 90. so
obviously what's gonna happen crushes
the battery uh it absolutely crushed the
battery at least that one that I had it
absolutely crushed it we had to tear we
did a seven hour ride 14 hours because
we had to charge so many times
you know the charging thing it's not
like you can't just like charge like
there's like certain Chargers that are
fast and some that are slow you know
like don't you just use the thing on the
screen that like tells you what to do
well it tells you where it tells you
where it tells you where the charges are
but I'm saying some of the charging
stations and some of the spots are fast
Chargers and some are slow like there's
a like it's like a gas pump where one
will fill it up at twice the speed as
the other so make sure when you do it
you know that so you go only to the fast
Chargers uh and none of the slow the
slow ones are like you you had to be
like I wanted to go watch a movie so
that I could do this slow charge no I I
use there's this app called a better
route I think it's called
like has built this whole like thing
just on routing out people's electric
charges and so I'm gonna use that but my
wife's my wife's flying and I was like
I'm driving I want to drive I want to
see what it's like and so I'm driving
and I'm gonna report back on Wednesday
to see how it feels I did it so I I'm
gonna leave tonight so I'll get a few
hours in and then tomorrow that way I
can like I plan my life around this pod
because I was like
it's we record 11 my time like I can't
arrive that morning otherwise I'll be
like tired I want better research right
so I have to plan it so I get there
Tuesday night but I need a full night's
rest so I can like wake up and like
research and [__] do you plan your life
around this pod oh yeah to an extent
right like you know
this is uh this is the one unmissable
appointment on my calendar everything
else yeah it's flexible this is the one
non-flexible thing it's no days off I
think I mean we've recorded on we missed
Christmas yeah so I guess we can't
really say that right now well wasn't
there like an issue yeah we had a sound
issue but uh we're like no days off
people are like you missed last the last
time that was like a technical error but
we've done like whatever the most recent
holiday is we're recording whatever I
think we've done Christmas Eve before we
always record big thanks to everybody
who listens this is a fun thing for us
to do thank you for listening uh yeah
this is like one of the one of the the
dope parts of our life and I think it's
attracted a bunch of little like uh
I mean neck beard Nation right so it's
attracted a bunch of people who whose
brain is weird in the way our brain is
weird and uh and I think that's a lot of
fun I want to end with this so I was at
this I'll tell you a very very quick
story I was at this La Tech Meetup first
of all our fans are that sounds weird
but our listeners they come in all
shapes and sizes man all colors oh I
like I love it like what does that mean
what are you trying to say there dude
like I had this guy that looked like he
was seven feet tall guy like basketball
player and I thought he was like a
famous guy and he comes up he goes total
man and he gave me like you know like
the black guy handshake I'm like
black guy you are a total man like that
you didn't even need to say it bro no
yes pure gaming like that got my
handshake you know what I'm saying and
uh and then I had this like 55 year old
woman who was with her kid at the
airport say what's up and I just want to
say first of all if you're a fan thank
you and second of all I can tell like
walking by if someone listens or not
because if they're wearing like
Lululemon ABC pants or like if they look
like they go to like Columbia uh like
University and they like make eye
contact with you in a particular way I
could tell and I would love for you to
come and say what's up so long as it's
like a quick like what's up total man
like you can say something by the way
here's the etiquette you come over
you fist pound not handshake or hug so
let's do nuts that's the way we do it
we're not trying to get a little too too
much uh I'm not trying to be pumped upon
with anybody and so uh give me the
knocks you can say uh you can reference
that you get no small boy stuff uh total
man you could use any of the any of the
isms that you want that just means
I know you and I'm I'll give you the
head nod back like yep you're one of us
take the selfie together and then uh and
then we kind of you know we keep the
show rolling from there but here's the
[__] that I need to announce to people
and they and we got with us in every
episode because
oftentimes if they send me with my wife
they'll say what's up they see me with
like my in-laws or up to eat with
friends they won't say what's up and
every once in a while they will and it
makes me feel so cool oh my God yo the
more people I'm with the more I need you
to be over the top with it yes my wife
doesn't listen to this podcast she's
never heard a single episode so she
doesn't think this is cool she thinks
this is me playing video games up in the
bedroom right now so only when she sees
someone come up in person and then even
you know I was with her mom there and
they were like wow what my dad was there
and he's like he my dad literally goes
he must have thought you're someone else
and family actually understand and so if
you see us out there please give us one
yeah if we're with friends you have to
do it Bella make my day I love the short
thing I was out to eat and like three
different guys when I was about to eat I
was at my co-workers I said what's up
and I played it up like oh man I can't
go anywhere
in my head I'm like
I'm like oh there's a forward I hope
there's a fourth it's someone and my
co-workers are like does this happen all
the time I'm like ah I gotta say the
most embarrassing version of this so uh
when we were selling the milk Road I
went to meet up with the guy who bought
it Kendall at a coffee shop and we're at
the coffee shop for a bit
and I see someone kind of like looking
like I think they recognize me but I'm
not sure and I'm like come over just
come over right now because he doesn't
listen to the podcast and I'm trying to
do this deal and I'm like I think it
would help if he felt like I'm a big
deal I was like I think that'd be a
little nicer yes the guy doesn't come
over right so we go outside we say I say
bye he starts walking away
and the guy comes over and he's like
Sean and I'm like yeah he goes hey man
you're like Vandal come back yeah I
literally go I was like oh Kendall I
want you to be my house I was like hey
uh have you met Kendall and you guys
like No And I was like Kendall yeah um
this guy just he listens to the party I
just wanted you to it didn't even make
sense and I was like I forced it so bad
dude
validate me please how do you take a
cool moment and make it the most lame
was me being like hey wait
you didn't hear that he recognized me
come here have you guys met of course
not oh my God I I've said that before
I'm like hey say what you said again but
do it in front of my in-laws
so I just this is the public service
announcement if you think you know us or
if you think it's us even if you only
think it's kind of us uh just take a
chance and say what's up and uh feel
free to be over at the top like yeah you
know it's awesome we love it uh it makes
me feel good and it more so makes me
look cool which is what I care about
more than anything
so anyway that's awesome that's the Pod
good episode
[Music]
foreign